[Musik]
1991 bleibt uns oder ist uns allen in
erinnerung geblieben die damals dabei
waren
egal ob die bevölkerung oder ob als
soldat im einsatz und zusammen 1991 war
doch sagen wir die schwierigste krise
die herren an der slowenischen grenze zu
bewältigen hatten an der damals an die
jugoslawischen grenze zu bewältigen
hatten
es war schlicht und einfach krieg und
wir werden unmittelbar daneben
der vielvölkerstaat jugoslawien hat sich
mehr oder weniger aufgelöst
ja die slowenen haben eben ihre
unabhängigkeit mehr oder weniger
ausgerufen
und dass man natürlich von der
slawischen volksarmee und auch für
darüber slawischen luftwaffe sehr
kritisch mit verfolgt und versucht es
wurde ihm versucht dies zu verhindern
und dabei kann es auch die luft
verletzungen von verletzungen
das des österreichischen luftraums ich
habe den auftrag mit meiner kompanie mit
sechs monate lang ausgebildet und
soldaten eine alarm compagnie am
sportplatz zu formieren das war grob in
den mittagsstunden und während dieser
formierung der alarm komponente für
einen allfälligen einsatz an der grenze
vorgesehen war donnerte ein jagdflugzeug
der damaligen jugoslawischen folgsam weg
mitten über den sportplatz ungefähr 50
meter über grund und ich habe eine
alarmmeldung luftraum vernetzung über
österreichisches staatsgebiet ein mann
in folge setzten das command abgesetzt
nach der alarmierung würde ja nicht nur
das überwachungs geschadet
nach graz verlegt sondern auch die
fliegerabwehr entsprechend alarmiert
die flieger abwehr hatte er den auftrag
den einsatz flugplatz cards thaler auf
entsprechend zu schützen
und wir haben uns im prinzip
fliegerische auf den flieger schnell
satz entsprechend vorbereitet um die
reaktionszeit aber entsprechend zu
verkürzen wurde während der jugoslawien
krise sehr oft eine sitze bereitschaft
eingeordnet das heißt da sitzen die
piloten diese alarmrotte im flugzeug auf
der stellfläche und mal laut im prinzip
nur auf die alarmieren gewartet und
betriebe um das triebwerk zu starten und
dann auch den staat durchzuführen
es war sehr heiß die flugzeuge standen
den ganzen tag auf der betonfläche im
freien im cockpit haben wir temperaturen
gemessen
über 50 grad und ich kann mich erinnern
dass wir wir hatten also sitz
bereitschaften derzeit davon bis zu zwei
stunden
und der einzige schutz der sehr uns
geboten hat war ein sonnenschirm über
dem cockpit und das war ja auch noch
eine besonderheit dieses einsatzes dass
der einsatzraum höhenmäßig limitiert war
weil er über hat der normale
linienflugverkehr und charter
flugverkehr stattgefunden
das heißt dass ein die
passagiermaschinen in den urlaub
richtung griechenland und in den süden
geflohen
[Musik]
von der alarmierung und vom einsatz
selbst war es eher so dass das militär
am anfang ja sehr in den hintergrund
getreten ist und nicht offensiv und
öffentlich auftreten dürfte an der
grenze obwohl es schon zwischenfälle
gegeben hat und aus meiner damaligen
sicht die alarmierung des bundesheeres
sehr spät erfolgt ist
wir soldaten waren vorbereitet wir sind
in der kaserne gewehr bei fuß gestanden
und wareneinsatz männer durften aus der
kaserne nicht heraus wir hatten viele
viele anrufe der bevölkerung wo seid ihr
wir brauchen euch jetzt wo wir euch
brauchen seid ihr nicht da es war für
uns und speziell für mich als junger
offizier eigentlich sehr belastend dass
wir der bevölkerung nicht beistehen
durften obwohl wir dazu bereit gewesen
wäre
[Musik]
oberst hubert nagel hat uns den auftrag
gegeben einen offizier spähtrupp für
eine grenznahe aufklärung zu binden und
dann sind wir in diesem wald bei bonus
daraufhin eingegangen um als allererste
tätigkeit festzustellen wo genau ist der
verlauf der geographische staatsgrenze
und alles für circa 100 150 meter im
wald waren haben wir auf einem nicht
bewaldeten hügel erkennen können dass
sich dort soldaten befinden
es waren sie doch aufgrund der
entfernung nicht möglich festzustellen
handelt es sich nun um soldaten der
jugoslawischen volksarmee oder
allenfalls und kräfte der slowenischen
territorialverteidigung persischer waren
wir sind auf österreichischen
staatsgebiet bei uns auch klar dass
diese soldaten ebenfalls auf äußeren
staatsgebiets erfolgt ein anruf vorerst
in englischer sprache
worauf da kann man dann dieser soldaten
antwortete ein sehr gut verständlichem
deutsch wir können deutsch miteinander
ohne diskussion hat er zur kenntnis
genommen dass sie natürlich österreich
verlassen müssen
und bevor wir auseinander gegangen sind
hat er sich noch informiert wie weit er
glaubt zurück gehen zu müssen dass er
mit sicherheit auf slowenisch im
stadtgebiet
ich war dann von herrn begrenze die wir
beobachtet haben wie die slowenische
oder jugoslawische klein caroli oder
kaserne beschlossen wurde in genthin
wir hatten dort aufgrund der
grenzziehung die möglichkeit das ganze
von der seite her zu beobachten und
hatten gesehen wurde die band sarah
abgefeuert wurden und wo die granaten
eingeschlagen haben und wie sich die
soldaten in diesem bereich verhalten
haben in den nächsten tagen gegen ende
juni hat sich der konflikt dann
zunehmend verschärft in den raum
radkersburg gornja radgona wie es heißt
ist eine ganze kompanie damaligen
jugoslawischen volksarmee eingedrungen
und wurde in relativ kurzer zeit von
soldaten des koreanischen territorial
verteidigungskräfte umzingelt und weil
vermutlich der banzer kommandant der
kompanie gedacht hat
dass die beobachtung in dieses zentrum
auf dem dorfplatz von ober radkersburg
aus dem kirchturm herunter erfolg der
dort überhöht gelegen ist hat er den
auftrag gegeben mit einem schuss der
bahn zur kanone ein kirchturm von
radkersburg herunter zu schießen
bei angenommen wurde es befindet sich
ein beobachter dass menschen der
revierverteidigung als beobachter am kit
[Musik]
wenn man dadurch die stellung gegangen
ist und das sind junge rekruten gesessen
mit 18 19 jahren
da hat meine entschlossenheit in den
gesichtern gesehen der soldaten die da
war und da hat man gewusst wenn jetzt
wirklich etwas sein sollte wenn eine
grenzverletzung stattfindet dann werden
unsere soldaten die verteidigung
durchführen die täterin umrichter ganz
gerne an die worte von oberst retten und
politikern der geschafft hat das stück
war uns sehr holte stück runter bester
partner in diesen entscheid und bestimmt
österreich hatte dringend notwendig wenn
kauf eines überschallflugzeuges eines
abfangjägers welche typen auch immer und
deswegen war für mich diese ganze die
politische debatte damals sehr
erschreckend
wenn man eben die gesamte vorgeschichte
des der 3 1 führung noch einmal revue
passieren lassen vertragen zuvor ein
sehr umstrittenes gerät war war er auch
unter anderem tituliert als der witwen
machen
politisch umstritten in allen medien
sehr negativ dargestellt und sicherlich
ist das meiner frau noch immer gut in
erinnerung
beim einkauf nicht tragisch und bei den
ersten einsätzen sich tragen dass in
österreich konnten wir feststellen dass
der verein ausgezeichnet das fluggerät
war wahrscheinlich bestätigt dass er
trocken war bis 2005 in einsatz
und wir hatten in österreich keinen
einzigen flugunfall eines tragen
damit bestätigte sich dass er seine
ausgezeichnete stück wie etwa und als
hier der erste demonstrationsflug mit
einer rotte tragen erfolgte hat es
standing ovations wie man heute sagt
also applaus der beteiligten
zivilpersonen die zu diesem zeitpunkt
auf dem bürgerhaus bevölkerten
hauptplatz von straßen liegen
vertrag kann war zu der zeit nur mit
einer bordkanone bewaffnet es waren auch
die bestimmungen zum waffengebrauch sehr
eingeschränkt die schüsse erlaubnis
hatten wir im prinzip nur zur
selbstverteidigung und zum selbstschutz
und hier gab es im staffel rahmen
zahlreiche diskussionen zum thema wie
erkennt man der luft tatsächlich dass
ich ein flugzeug nicht freundlich
verhält sondern sondern eben zum gegner
wird aber dieser dieser einsatz 91 war
dann letztendlich eigentlich
ausschlaggebend für zeitnahe folge
beschaffungen bekamen also eine infrarot
gesteuerte lenkwaffe und der draken
wurde auch mit einem selbstschutz system
ausgestattet getragen wurde er damals
von auch ein militärs nicht nicht nur
für die bevölkerung negativ bewertet als
altes oder sehr alte und ungeeignete
flugzeug selbst hat eigentlich das
gegenteil bewiesen
[Musik]